hello everybody I'm finally back from my
two-week stint in Boston and Austin
Texas four packs and South by Southwest
gaming it has been an incredibly busy
three weeks for me because right before
the convention I actually planned
everything out I planned that I was
gonna be like oh yeah I'm gonna go see
my friends I'm gonna do a panel I'm
gonna have lots of fun and I'm gonna
have all my videos ready but then Scott
Cawthon decided to say oh hey Mark
here's five nights at Freddy's 3 and I
went ah [ __ ] everyone in the whole world
wants me to play that so I got to play
that and I'm I'm honored that you guys
do turn to my videos for five nights at
Freddy's I don't know how I became like
the five nights at Freddy's guy but I'm
really honored that yeah because the
first video in the third game has like
10 million views already and that's that
boggles my mind because that's more
people than I have subscribers and I'm
starting to realize what the impact of
that is and what the implications of
what that means is when I go to these
conventions and I go to these
conventions to see you guys and also see
my friends and I got to meet Jack for
the first time and I got to see Bob and
Wade again that I got to see yamimash
again I've got to play more games with
the yamimash real soon but I got to meet
jacket and this is what I'm gonna talk
about right now because what I saw in
Jack was exactly what I wanted to see
from him because I watched his video his
best weekend ever video and it describes
his own experience and I watched through
the whole thing and I I hate to mimic it
because he just kept doing this through
the whole video he just said like oh
this is so cool in his Irish accent that
he does and it was amazing to see
because he in his video he says that he
was calm and collected on the outside
like yep uh-huh
and I can assure you that was not the
case like I looked over at him
especially when the first throngs of
fans started to make their way towards
us and and that's totally fine by the
way I am there to meet you guys I'm not
saying that in a bad light but when the
first mob
became at us you know I looked over and
the first thing I saw was shock just
like this is real this is really
happening these people are here in the
real they really want to meet us and
then late he I knew he was gonna get a
ton
he's very popular and whatnot and then I
got a ton to just because apparently I'm
popular for some strange reason and then
I just saw the shock turned to wonder in
his eyes I hate to turn it into a Disney
tailor some magical fairy adventure but
it was really true because I saw in his
eyes the same thing that I saw in Bob
and Wade the first time that we got you
know mobbed by fans and you know I saw
that Wonder the realization that all of
this is real and it's the same
realization that I had you know a like a
year and a half ago or two years ago or
probably like all the way back to the
first time that I ever met a fan at a
convention which was the San Diego Comic
Con about three years ago now and it was
the realization that the people out
there are really real I mean you can
tell yourself that and you know that in
your heart that the people who are
subscribing you're real and you know
that and you say that and you really
really believe it but it changes when
people are really in front of you and
they tell you so much that they care
about what you do and they love what you
do and they love the videos you make and
they they respect what you do and like
the realization I saw on his face and I
was I was you know I'm so happy you know
I was happy because I saw and it was
like yes this guy is exactly who I
thought he was this guy he's the coolest
and any block it blows my mind that he
says that he looks up to me
for inspiration and and in a way he's a
fan of me and that blows my mind because
I saw his videos way back when and when
I first reached out to and I was like
hey you're a cool Irish dude you make
cool videos I love your accent oh you
know you want to make a video with me
and he said yeah and I was like cool and
who's like cool and we did the video
together and that was just the start of
it and then I got to know him and I got
to talk with him and you know like with
any friend that I met you know I'm very
very picky about you know the people
that I interact with and
people that I call friends but I could
call jack friend I call you la même a a
good friend of mine I go Bob and Wade
good friends obviously even wait wait
he's a good friend just cuz you know
it's about the people in you know it's
so cool to see that he is so
understanding of the world that this is
in the weird world that we're in and all
may attacks I can't even describe the
words to say exactly how cool was
because every second that I was on the
patch show floor I was meeting fans of
endless meeting fans from start to
finish I got through the door I didn't
even get up to the doors of the
Convention Center before fans started
coming up and saying hi to me
and that's totally fine I like I want to
reiterate that is absolutely fine and I
love it to death I'm so happy that you
guys find joy in my videos and find
entertainment out of what I do every day
and that's the biggest honor that I
could possibly have and I got to see you
know yamimash again and I get to see him
and I got to see Bob and Wade again and
I was so happy to be able to do another
panel with a thousand people in it a
thousand people were in a panel and I
know that's nothing compared to the six
and a half million subscribers that I
have but just seeing a thousand people
will like change your perspective I mean
being in front of them and having the
only reason that they are there and
having the knowledge that they waited in
line for hours and hours just to be
there and that some people were even
turned away because they didn't get
there soon enough they didn't wait long
enough and and it blows my mind that it
reaches that level and I'm so you know
I'm so happy that I'm able to be there
because you know I it's the same thing I
was saying when I was doing my 6 million
subscriber the milestone video that Mark
Blair sings badly does you know is the
same thing that I was saying back then
when you see every single person or not
even every single person but when you
see the individual person and you know
that one person out there is exactly the
same as another person and you know the
difference is that they may have don't
matter in that they are there to support
you it's it's a really humbling
experience in
goddamn I I wish I could do it more but
I'm starting to realize that I'm really
spread thin I mean especially because
when I went to South by Southwest gaming
I was hosting the gaming Awards over
there and that was a cool experience
which I'll get to in just a second but I
was there alone you know I was there by
myself I didn't have Bob or weight or
Jack her young match there and and it
was I was so interesting to see it from
that perspective because I was totally
alone and I was unsupported by anyone
else and it was just me out there and I
didn't have a panel or anything but I
was walking the convention floor I was
meeting people and I'm saying hi to
everyone and I had people just screaming
and crying meeting me and I was just
like no don't cry it's okay I'm I'm me
I'm real I'm just a dude I play game
some wearing pants right now but that's
okay and you know it's it was it was an
interesting experience because I did I
didn't have anyone else there though
with me to enjoy it with cuz you know I
had you guys and you guys obviously were
enjoying with me but there's something
about having someone on the sidelines
that I can look over and I can know that
they're you know they understand them
they not in agreement or something and
you know every time I looked over I just
saw the booth said I was blocking up and
they're like are you are these people
here for us or what are you doing here
you're gonna move along here but it's so
you know it's so weird to know that now
that I'm back in LA I I you know I'm
back with some good friends that I have
now you know and I just wish that I
could do more you know I said that a lot
but you know I wish I could do more for
you guys and I know I wish I could do
more for the world and I wish I could do
more for my friends because my friends
are the like I've I'm so lucky to have
the coolest friends in the world who are
willing to god damnit I'm sorry
ah I'm so lucky to have the coolest
friends in the world that are so
supportive of what I do in and the
things that I appreciate in life and the
things I want to do and I'm I'm just you
know I'm honored cuz people look up to
all I'm trying to do is just get through
this goddamn video and all I'm trying to
do is make people laugh and that's all
I've ever wanted to do and that's all
I'm ever going to want to do and I just
want you know to make one person's day
brighter that's why I don't care if
people don't like my videos that's
totally fine people are allowed not to
like my videos people are allowed to not
like me that's totally fine I'm okay
with that
and it's it just it's the coolest thing
in the world to know that even one
person you know even one person will
enjoy what I do and even one person will
get a little bit of happiness out of
what I do and that makes it all worth it
and I I mean I'm sorry I'm getting
rambling when I'm supposed to be talking
about the the gaming Awards that I had
and I hosted was Janet Varney that was
so cool I mean I reach this level where
I'm the hosting Awards like why why do I
deserve this and when I was up there
like I was I was nervous at first just
because it was a scripted event and
there was rules and there was a show
list and we had a method that we were
supposed to do we were supposed to stick
to the rules but then I discovered
quickly that when I went up there the
rules didn't matter I was able to do
whatever I wanted I could I could make
people creature whenever I wanted and
cry and weep openly if I had so much fun
up there and I know some people saying
people were out of control in the
audience but to be honest like that's
how I'd rather have it you know I'd
rather have it interactive and open and
honest like that and I don't think
anyone who was running the show even
minded but it was so cool because I got
to meet Janet Varney and I don't even
watch The Legend of Korra but I know and
respect that she's an actual like
celebrity celebrity and I'm just
youtuber and it's it was so amazing to
see because I was up on stage in front
of people and I've never been nervous
doing public speaking and as soon as I
hit my stride I was totally fine but I
was looking at up at all these games
that I was just seeing like oh that game
I went to play that but I didn't have
time oh there's another one I meant to
play but I didn't have time and it was
like the one the one thing that I wish I
had more of was time
I wish I had more time because you know
I was only able to do one video a day
for a long time here while I was gone
and I apologize for that
I wish she was different but I'm trying
my best you know I'm gonna get back into
the swing of things as soon as I get
done with this video and actually be
able to record something worthwhile but
it's just it was so amazing to see
because like after I got done with the
awards like I know that you know my
family was so proud of me and I talked
about my dad a lot and I don't mean to
talk about him all that much but you
know I just know that my dad would have
been so proud of me but at the same time
I know right now my mom is so proud of
me and my zem mom is so proud of me my
the rest of my family they're so proud
of what I've done my hometown is proud
of me like people that I went to high
school with her is suddenly very proud
of me and I'm like what did i do what
did I do to deserve this
and his coolest feeling in the world
because I know that so many people look
up to me and I'm just a big bubble
blowing baby in front of a camera but I
just know that I'm you know I'm I'm
proud I'm proud of what I've done you
know
I'm so proud of what we've done together
ah god damn I'm really proud of what
we've managed to accomplish and I'm so
proud of what we're gonna do I'm so
proud of you guys for believing in me
I'm so happy that you do ah I'm tryin to
ah I didn't mean to get mopey about this
at all but I can't help it sometimes cuz
it just means so much to me to know that
you guys there for me and then meet so
much know that my friends are there for
me my family and I'm so lucky even
though I've been through like people say
I've been through a lot of hardship I
don't know about that I think pain makes
you stronger sometimes but like I've
just I've been so happy to be able to do
this and I know it won't last forever I
don't expect it to I don't want it to
you know but yeah I just want to do so
much more you know I'm gonna have a
swear I'm gonna like I could buy her
anything I don't know why I'm getting
all mopey about it but like I want any
more videos with yamimash Bob and Wade
and jacket out I just want to do more
videos and meet more cool people and I
just wanna I just want to keep going and
doing this for as long as I can and I
want to do other things like I'm gonna
explore like trying to take singing
lessons and learn guitar and piano how I
want to do the things that I've always
wanted to do hi this is just a matter of
time huh man god I wish I had more time
yeah that's what ever once anyway I'm
sorry I got weird and mopey and stuff
like that but I I just wanted to say
that this was even though is the busiest
it was one of the coolest periods of
time that I've had in my life and I'm so
honored that you guys trust me and
believe
and want me to succeed and even for
those that don't I'm okay with that too
like I understand I totally understand
my videos are sometimes very weird and
dated fare is changed but hey that's
just a tag I wouldn't have them any
other way to be honest so I'll finish up
here just thank you guys so much for
being there for me and thank you guys so
much for being there for each other and
the community that's being built and I
know some people have grievances with it
but to be honest I'm so proud of you
guys you guys are you guys are the
greatest community that I've ever known
and you're the greatest group of people
that I've ever known so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for being there thank you everyone that
went out to those conventions that I'm
sorry to those that I didn't get to meet
I'm holding one guy
I'm spread really thin but thank you
guys nonetheless thank you thank you
thank you I can't say thank you enough
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye